jeff snyder here for collider and i'm
sitting down with the team behind the
novice which premieres at the tribeca
film festival this week we have
writer director and editor lauren
hattaway and stars isabel fuhrman and
dalon thank you so much for joining me
thank you thank you so lauren you know
with these festival films where the
public doesn't really
know what they're about you know there's
no trailer out yet or anything
why don't you tell the folks at home
sort of you know what this movie is all
about and where it came from
it sort of follows an obsessive
collegiate rower who's trying to climb
the ranks of her
her cutthroat team and for me i based it
on my own um
you know it's a sports film but it's not
a sports film it's a film about grit and
ambition
and it's inspired by my own uh years as
a collegiate rower and i
essentially took four years of that
experience and ten years of coming of
age
and pushed into this film and tried to
make a really visceral kind of bizarre
um experience to to really
show the audience put them in the scene
to know so that they know what it feels
like to connect with
like what it means to be obsessed with
something whether or not they've rode
which is probably 99.9
of people who will ever watch this film
so so you're a former rower yourself
how much of this like was based on what
you went through in your own experience
and how much was sort of
you know embellished from the
imagination though everything that you
see happening in terms of the injuries
or the team dynamics or the
whatever that all the bad stuff that
happens i've
those happen to me they happen to
someone on the team or they tap into
people i've talked to you know when i
was making this film
um and talking to different people i
talked to an olympian uh
olympic rower and she was telling me
stories about the infected blisters and
the things like that
and when she told me that i was like
holy [ __ ] like that it's extreme like
you're pushing yourself so far
that you literally might kill yourself
doing a sport like this is the thing
that happens and rovers are obsessed
they're neurotic
you're doing the same thing on loop
staring in the back of someone's head
over and over and over and over it takes
a type of person um and so
that for me you know i wrote in sort of
my
wrong i was obsessed with it i wrote in
four years of that sort of experience
this was my catharsis writing this
and over the two years between the first
draft and when we shot the film
as my life happened i would write in
various life events personal events
um breakups things like that and really
try to uh
you know milk the film for everything
and um
deal with my own uh life i guess
and so uh isabel what were you sort of
uh what attracted you to the project was
it the physical challenge i mean
were you looking for something like this
at this point in your career
i definitely feel like that was a huge
part of it
i had been thinking for so many for such
a long time i was like i want to do like
a movie where i play a superhero but
not like a typical superhero and i
really feel like in a sense i got the
the whole like transformation aspect um
with this movie
and got to be like a rowing superhero
but what
really kind of attracted me to it was
once i read the script um and
i i said this in an earlier interview
that i didn't even realize this until
lauren and i had been together in person
like
recently uh that i was so
um caught by the emotion of going after
a goal and having a very specific idea
in mind of what
i wanted to achieve by a certain age i
from the time that i was about 14 to 19
as a like in the acting industry i had
so many ideas of like where i wanted to
be in my career at 16 and
wanted to have this kind of role when i
was 18 and i wanted to have this kind of
award when i was 20 and it's like i felt
like i was
closing in on myself and really kind of
losing um like social aspect of my life
uh i was so set on achieving this goal
and when i read the script
i didn't i didn't even realize that
subconsciously that's what attracted me
to play alex um
and lauren was the one who saw that in
me which is probably what she asked me
um but i i taped my audition for
for the movie and i picked another scene
that i remember reading in the script
and feeling
like i just understood exactly what
lauren was trying to
say in that scene and covered myself in
sweat and
and everything did make up to make
myself look like i was like exhausted
and i wrote lauren a letter then
afterwards telling her why she had to
pick me
for this role and that nobody else could
play this part but me and
i think she saw not only that part of me
that connected with alex but also
somebody so obsessive enough that i went
so far above and beyond what i was
supposed to do just because i
really wanted it you know i'm curious
about the letter
and delona i have a question for you uh
in just a second but
lauren do letters like that sway you or
is it all about what shows up on camera
in the audition i'm genuinely curious
um it's it's it's both because i wasn't
the only letter that i got
and i appreciate if i get them i read
them absolutely 100
but if the person's not right for the
part they're not right for the part but
it was like
she did the scene that one of the you
know i'd given to the things i had given
two scenes with the casting directors
and i only found out later i only got
one seen back on all the actors and that
they had only sent out one scene but
isabelle intuitively had chosen the
second scene that i wanted to see
and she the scene that i had given half
the people like misinterpreted it she
had that reading right she had
everything and like
i was telling the story isabelle first
hated the story but i think now she's
come around
to it i think over the years but it's
like when it comes to casting this is my
first rodeo and i really tried to rely
on and study the career and advice about
the directors and i saw the screening
with um
david fentry he said something after the
interview where he said when he cast
someone for a role he really tries to
understand who the person is at their
core
because at the end of 12 hour day of ben
affleck is not batman he's been athletic
and right so and so when it came to cast
isabelle she did all these other her
auditions were superb
and she did all these other things then
meet her in in real life and she's got
this [ __ ] binder and these little
tabs and all these different things
and like this energy effect which is
very peppy she's not like this murderous
uh
child actor you know her from believe it
or not she doesn't kill people so
i when her energy was like oh my god
she's so
like not crazy but she is in a different
sort of way and she has a strive and
intensity and it really
um i don't know i mean she she was right
and the letter just added to it and what
she wrote in the letter about running
from
la to las vegas and having an injury and
all this stuff it was just like the
combination of all of it
uh dalon you play isabelle's ta in the
film who sort of you know strikes up a
relationship with her what did you see
in the script that made you want to make
the transition from model to actress
yeah well you know i've been modeling uh
like last seven years of my life
and so i had been studying acting for a
few years now
and i've been i was looking for a role
that like really spoke to me for a while
and i didn't want to just do anything
and when i got this
audition i was so excited because it was
like everything i wanted you know i'm a
queer woman
of color and i got to be a lesbian that
is really smart you know
she gets into the college of her own
choice she plays a teacher's assistant
and um she's creative and she's you know
you know just as ambitious as
alex but in like a really healthy way
you also get to
you know see the softer sides of alex
while we're together
um because um i have this nurturing
aspect so i felt like the
role was really relatable um for my
first role and also something that
would still be challenging and new and
um i just thought uh when i found out
like isabelle was doing it i was so
excited
and then lauren being um this queer
woman as well
i was like i was still on board and do
do you see any parallels between
modeling and rowing in terms of what it
takes to succeed
there's definitely this obsession and
like in regards to this
like it's really easy for you to be like
i gotta be the best and i'm gonna do
it like this and you kind of just like
you can become a little self-absorbed
and like just like
think about what it is that you need to
achieve rather than thinking about the
bigger picture like
the entire production um uh yeah so i i
can definitely
see similarities and i mean i couldn't
take my eyes off of alex when i was
watching the film i was just like oh my
god i i related to it so much
uh and isabelle is a young actress in
this business i mean have you ever felt
like you had to push yourself to the
extremes that that alex does in this
film in order to get a role
in order to get a role you know it's
funny i feel like i've been
really fortunate that the the
the roles that have come my way um very
often
it's like one or two auditions and
people that
i i audition with know the ones that
i've like really
you know multiple auditions long process
i never get those jobs which is so funny
and i think it's because intuitively
people know
when they meet someone you click with
that person with that person's energy
and if
they are what you're looking for in your
script it's like well there's nobody
else it's like this is what fits and
this is what works
um but i you know i felt like even in
this process of preparing for
this movie i really felt like i was like
the lines were so blurred in terms of
like where was isabelle where was alex i
mean i was waking up at five in the
morning and rowing for three hours
and then i had like an hour to sleep and
eat something and then i was rowing
again for another
like two three hours as we were getting
closer to filming because
i rode every single scene in the movie i
didn't have a double for that
so i had this intense pressure on myself
i mean i was messaging lauren and i was
like i can't get this thing right and
it's just bothering the hell out of me
because
i was like i have to look convincing i
have to look like i could
be the person that makes it to the top
of the bone and if i don't i can't
achieve that then
no one's gonna believe the whole movie
and uh
i felt like at the end of those like
rowing days i would go work with a
physical trainer my friend beck wilcock
trained me for the movie for two hours
and i would do weights with her and then
i'd have auditions and meetings and
things at the end of the day and i
remember
like the lines were so blurred i had no
idea what day it was i was like sleeping
and rowing and eating and that was
it's essentially it and when i got on
set i was like
wow it's like i really feel like i've
found this character and as much as i
like had done like
prep like lauren said my binder with
like all of these tabs
like really the most that i connected
with her was in the water
on the boat being in that kind of mode
of like
learning something new and having to
learn as fast as i could
because i really felt this pressure of
like i had to be the best on set
even though we were rowing with like
people who actually knew what it was
like i really felt like i had to be the
best
because i had to look convincingly
enough that i could be the best
um and i really learned a lot during
preparation for this movie i can imagine
i mean lauren i was going to ask about
that the other girls who
who populate the team um were those you
know collegiate rowers people who had
experience or were they you know actors
who you just sort of trained up
um the only other everyone was a real
rover aside from amy who plays jamie she
also had her own little uh boot camp she
was shooting a film at the time and
was like on her days off she would be at
the boathouse basically rotting there
all day like isabelle doing her own
thing um but then everyone else we had a
casting director local to toronto was
great went to every single uh
every single boathouse in a two hour
radius was like talking to people going
out there five in the morning we got a
ton of like uh
improv auditions called it down from
there then we did auditions that way
then the girls who were chosen we did
like a little acting
uh workshop with them uh and um
yeah so everyone that you see in the
film they they did their rowing they're
real rowers
and uh hopefully you know that people do
grow can sense that and sense the
sort of intensity we wouldn't have been
able to do it without them
i mean amy and i as much as we worked
hard and trained hard
like the complication of setting a boat
with
three people four people eight people
like we needed
those girls with us because those boats
would have flipped like a million times
a day we were constantly just like
so grateful to have them because not
only were they
exceptional rowers but they were
wonderful wonderfully game to like play
and do this and like
to row back and forth the same way all
day which is something as an actor used
to but if you're
you know physically exercising i
remember the first time they were like
what do you mean we're going again
i was like we're going to be doing this
all day good
we're going to be doing this all day
i really like that scene too where you
where you go up to the front of the boat
because it shows how claustrophobic it
is and how it's like
there's no uh leaving the boat like you
you are a team and you are there all day
um i just i just thought that uh having
played team sports it was an interesting
dynamic
um it felt like that we were filming if
we had to go to the bathroom we would
just
lean outside what else are you gonna do
i mean
um lauren i wanted to ask how you even
got to this this point because uh you
know i understand that
you started out as like a dialogue an
adr editor working in sound so so how do
you get this chance to direct your own
feature
um it's funny you know i saw as when i
was 15 i before i've always been writing
i've always been making my own little
films i was 15 though i saw
kill bill for the first time and it blew
my mind and i knew at that moment i
wanted to be a director
fast forward three years and i get to
college and all these guys
with all their camera i was very few
women on team
immediately imposter syndrome hit but
you know i loved editing and discovered
sound fell into that no one else was
really doing it
decided i wanted to do a sound career i
come to la i didn't
know where to start i was like i don't
there's no direction and so i set a goal
tarantino and i worked backwards and
eventually did and when i was 25 i
worked with tarantino working on turn
penal film and that was a dream come
true for me
and i think it really gave me the
confidence um that my other career
successes around that time to like you
know what i can write and direct i have
stories i want to tell i'm ready to tell
them i'm ready to be sort of
honest and open and talk about these
things with people because before
you know now i'm pretty wearing bright
red shirts and whatever doing my thing
but
before it was very kind of closed off
and sort of robotic and um
isolated from the world so i don't think
it was ready to really
write and be true and whatever and so
then i wrote this script you know when
you when i made this
goal november 2016 to transition into
writing and directing within five years
i wanted to i studied the careers of
directors i've admired damian chazelle i
really admire his career i love what he
did with whiplash and like making a film
that only you can tell a story only you
can tell
and that was his film and i sent a
script to um
my ryan who came on as a producer he i
went to college with him
uh we both went to smu and he came on
board and i found another producer
through
uh the blacklist like the site where you
host scripts
these two guys were totally different i
like linked them up they joined together
joined forces the best of those worlds
and then
started pitching in now and over the
next two years it slowly kind of came
together
and in that time too i really try to use
you know dialogue editing and adr people
don't even know what that is it's not
very sexy but you're basically in a room
with like the actors re-recording lines
for noise or they you're an action movie
you have to rewrite the entire film
later to explain it because it's changed
or whatever and so i got to spend a lot
of time
in the room with some really amazing
directors and actors
and a lot of times directors can't be in
the adr room they don't want to be in a
room no one really loves it and so it
gave me a lot of opportunity to work
with actors in that way
and so i tried to really observe and
learn and spend time talking to
directors and
just sponging it all up so when it came
time to
shoot the film you know i had no idea
what i was doing but i don't think
anyone does actually which is the
beautiful thing
that you learn when you start working in
this industry we're all just kind of
faking it
i think that's adulthood so yeah
um dalon uh i have not yet
caught up with halston but it is at the
top of my screening queue on netflix i
know you play pat cleveland on that show
can you talk to me about your experience
on that project and prepping to play a
real life model
i got uh pat after i did um the novice
and
they actually came they were looking for
real models so they didn't go through my
um my acting agency and
they went to my modeling agency at the
time dna and they said they're looking
for models and my agents were like well
if you want someone that can spin and
tour like that then
you have to take delon so i actually
have worked with pat
a ton and i i i know her family
pretty well and you know they wished me
well and they were so
they were excited to see me playing her
she
for me is such an icon and i'm i'm so
inspired by her
before i even got the rule like before
even knowing about it i would have
people sending me
um really old videos of her on the
runway saying like
like this is you oh my god like this was
your era you should have been in this
era so
i kind of felt like i manifested this in
a way
um she's so dreamy and colorful and the
way she talks about art and fashion and
you know i'm the director gave me her
autobiography so i read her
her book and i got to learn more about
her um uh and
you know there's really a story there
and i'm hoping like
maybe a spin-off of pat cleveland or
something because there's
she's just so wonderful i could i could
see it um
i i'm definitely going to check out
halston before the end of the month i've
heard great things about it
um isabel i know i know you are
reprising your
breakout role as esther and orphan first
kill
i'm curious you know what can you tease
about that prequel and i don't know
maybe how like julia stiles fits into
the story this time around
well it's definitely not what i think
most people will expect which i think is
really exciting and what really drew me
to
even coming back to playing that role
and i think also what i think is most
exciting about it is it's something
that's never been done cinematically
there's never been an adult actress
who's replies the role that she played
as a child
and that was exceptionally difficult
and really fun to do because when i was
a kid and i played esther
i was constantly playing a 33 year old
but hiding herself as a kid while i was
also 10
and this time i was like oh well here's
a little weight off my shoulders i just
have to pretend to be cat
i was like this is i'm already an adult
so
there we go um but kind of like what
lauren said you know fake until you make
it
you know i just was like it was really
cool to be back on that set i think
people will be
shocked by the story it's very different
than
um what most people would expect and
julia
is just absolutely incredible in it and
we had a lot of fun making the movie
together it's definitely more of a story
about the two of us and our relationship
um and kind of esther's way that she
came to the united states and how she
found herself there
so it's very exciting you're an
associate producer on that project
do we have any idea of when it might be
released
they're saying very soon i mean we we're
very very excited about it
uh yeah also it's just very trippy
because
i again like seeing things and seeing
myself as like a kid again is
very very trippy so i've kind of still
been like coping with that
and they're all handling the rest of
that sort of stuff i'm like this is so
wild
how did we do this um but
actually nav has helped me prepare for
that movie because i spent the majority
of the movie squatting because
i i had to walk around and learn how to
walk like basically in a squat
because i'm taller than you know the
average 10 year old
i don't know i know some pretty tall 10
year olds out there um
uh lauren um you know in perusing your
sound credits and stuff i
i saw that you worked on on justice
league and the snyder cut and
i'm curious what you made of like the
the online discourse surrounding that
project and whether you think it'll lead
to more
directors cuts in the future um
you know it's it's a good question and i
just read the other day i was reading
some kind of buzzfeed
20 film stories you couldn't believe and
you know i read the thing again about
the sonic
character that they redid yeah yeah um
and i think you know in the age of
social media
and all these different things the fan
base you know it's just
such a different world i think it's
gonna become more prevalent i mean
i don't know i was i was surprised i
worked on it i started working on
justice league in 2016
at the time zach was uh was on it and
then
he you know we the reshoots happened
with joss and then the movie came out
and then the fanboys did their thing and
then i get a call this past summer
and like we're gonna do justice again we
want you back to do the
the the what i couldn't i couldn't
believe it honestly i didn't think it
was gonna work because i
you know i was watching the the reddit
the fanboys doing all this thing and i
was like never in a million years but it
worked and the sonic thing worked
and so i don't know if that's a good i
mean i think for the designer cut it's a
great thing i don't know if in general
and
in the sonic film it turned out better
and everyone's really happy with it so
maybe it's a good thing it's also a
little terrifying so uh
i don't know right
i imagine it's scary being a filmmaker
and being now accountable to social
media and they have a voice in the
process it almost feels like in some of
these places
yeah um okay we have just a few more
minutes left uh
isabel i wanted to ask you since you
started in the movie cell i'm curious if
you have a favorite stephen king book or
adaptation
you know what's funny is for someone
who's done a lot of scary movies i don't
read scary books and i do not watch
scary movies
so i can't honestly answer that
first human king movie that i mean book
that i read
was that one and i was like i have free
to do research and uh
yeah but i i really i met stephen king
and i think he's wonderful
absolutely wonderful i'd love to read
one of his books i just don't really
like scary stuff
we gotta find you one like you know the
stand by me novella or shawshank
redemption or something
yeah yeah uh delone as you continue to
make a name for yourself as an actress
what kind of roles are you hoping to be
offered and is there like an actress's
career path you'd like to emulate
yeah i mean i love uh zoe zelda in his
career um
i really am into like sci-fi i got to do
drama
for the novice um i got to play
something more relatable and fashion for
halston and then
i've also done um i have a supporting
role for
something that mindy kaling is doing
called sex lives with college girls
which i got to experience like the
comedy side of things and that for me
was so exciting we were
laughing so much on set and honestly i i
want to i'd love to do more of that
and then also you know i had to audition
um
uh for doing the novice um
i had to audition singing
for this part and actually you know you
got they ended up picking up one of my
songs that i wrote with my friend
nigel so doing more roles where i get to
explore like being an artist in that way
too
i think will be a lot of fun i think
you'd make a great you know just
watching you in in this movie i
kind of think you'd make a badass action
star like in an alien or predator movie
or something
i want to watch you in a sci-fi movie so
bad yeah
um uh now isabel i understand you're
also like uh
writing a movie yourself titled princess
i'm curious
you know uh
i've been writing for a very long time
but i wrote an adaptation
of a little princess when i was like i
would say
12 13. um and we were gonna make it for
a time
um and i think financing was going up
and down and then i
aged out of it and then because i wrote
it and i wanted to do it it just kind of
like
fell apart and it's funny it's i know
it's still on imdb which is hilarious
uh but i am i am i currently that's part
of the reason why i'm traveling because
i'm doing research for a project that
i'm writing and for a documentary film
that i'm putting together so
i am yeah i'm create creating my own
stuff
and i'm gonna i'm gonna create a sci-fi
movie for you
stallone i wanna see i wanna see you in
a sci-fi movie
um that's all i was getting is whether
you had writing and directing
aspirations of your own
um and then and then finally uh lauren i
don't know this project is just coming
out
and you get to enjoy the big tribeca
debut and everything but have you
started thinking what's next for you
yeah i mean i i i'm doing revisions on a
lesbian sex comedy right now that i
wrote during a
summer before we shot novice in the
middle of real time as i was going
through a breakup
and it was my catharsis for that and uh
so i'm doing that and i uh i moved to
paris
when i started learning french as a
pandemic hobby um and it sort of
snowballed when i realized i wasn't
going to be able to go to paris
last summer i decided i guess i'm just
going to move there and live there
instead so now i live here and i hope
you know hopefully can
i'm trying to get involved with the
french film industry here and writing a
project and
my french is not where it needs to be
but i love for a year i only watched
french films and tv shows um
and fell in love with french culture
more than i already had
and so i hope one day maybe project
three uh
it can make something out here that'd be
great by the way
record her french is so good her friend
it is very good
it is way better than she thinks it is
yeah
for sure thank you so much uh you know
the team behind the novice debuting at
tribeca film festival make sure to check
it out
and thank everyone thank you all for
joining me
good luck with the film